un margen de 7 horas para deponer las
armas la noche del sábado Rusia dio un
ultimátum a las últimas tropas
ucranianas que protegen la ciudad de
maripopol Rendirse o Morir las fuerzas
armadas rusas les dan a los militantes
de batallones nacionalistas y
mercenarios extranjeros desde las 6
horas Moscú del 17 de abril del 2022
para dejar todas las hostilidades y de
poner las armas se garantiza perdonar
las vidas a todos los que depongan las
armas
además clarificaron que las tropas
tenían hasta la una de la tarde en hora
de Moscú para Rendirse el presidente
celenski había emitido previamente un
ultimátum propio
la eliminación de nuestras tropas de
Nuestros hombres en Mario pale pondrá
fin a cualquier negociación
los rusos han dedicado los últimos días
a estrechar el cerco en la ciudad
portuaria su objetivo alcanzar el
gigante distrito metalúrgico de la
ciudad donde se refugian los soldados
ucranianos de extrema derecha del
Batallón una de las plantas industriales
más grandes de Europa la planta
siderúrgica y de hierro es Hostal es un
laberinto de edificios con pasillos bajo
tierra la fábrica se extiende a lo largo
de millas frente al mar y es el último
gran punto de resistencia de Mario Paul
capturar mariupol es clave para Rusia y
para los separatistas sería una victoria
simbólica tras el fracaso de la
conquista de kiev